MEMBER WARD NOTICES THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM THE SERGEANTS AT
ARMS WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER
AND BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA. OKAY HERE
BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW.
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
CALDERON RUBIO CERVANTES CHEN
CHOI COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM
DALLY DALY DAVIES FLORA MIKE
FONG VINCE FONG FRIEDMAN APRIL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY BLACKY LOUIS
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA WHEN.
DONALD PATTERSON HOURS QUIRK
QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS REYES LOOSE
REEBOKS ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SEYARTO
SMITH STONE TEAM BALLOT ERRORS
THE VALLAPUDUA VOEPEL WALDRON
BOARD WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WE ASK OUR GUESTS. AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YES YOUR CON. YOU
MONEY IF YOU'RE. IN THE NAME OF
GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY GOD. GRANT
THE MEMBERS OF THIS ASSEMBLY TO
GRACE TO LISTEN TO ONE ANOTHER
WITH OPEN MINDS AND HEARTS. ME
THE CLARITY AND CHARITY OF THEIR
WORDS REFLECT RESPECT FOR THE
COLLINGS. GIVE THEM AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEEDS OF
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS. IN
THIS STATE OR OFTEN IGNORED.
WHOSE VOICES CRY OUT TO BE HEARD
. AS YOU HAVE BLESSED THIS LAND
WITH ABUNDANCE. HELP THE MEMBERS
OF THIS ASSEMBLY AND ALL OF US.
TO BE GENEROUS TO THE NEEDIEST
OF PERSONS. WITH THE GENEROSITY
THAT ONLY YOU CAN MAKE POSSIBLE.
I MEAN. WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US IN THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN NEW GRANDFATHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE. WITH
GRATITUDE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. STATES OF. YEAH.
ONE OUR INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY
AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MARCH TENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE ASSEMBLY
REDDIT NINETY M. THE AUDIBLE
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE
IF THIS IN THE PRESIDING TO
FOLKS WHO PARK AT THE DESK
READING CLERK DAVID BOWMAN
READING WILL CALL THE ROLL WAS
CALLED. MOVES IN MR GALLAGHER
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE IS A
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. PARTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE. THERE ARE NONE. MOVING
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GIPSON MCCARTY
AND ROBERT RIVAS TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RESCIND THE
ACTION WHEREBY ON FEBRUARY TENTH
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO SB FIVE
OH FOUR BECKER WAS READ A THIRD
TIME. URGENCY CLAUSE ADOPTED AND
PASSED IN THE SENATE PLEASE
ORDER THE BILL TO THE THIRD
READING FILE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY
FOUR FRIEDMAN FROM THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. TO THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM AND
INTERNET MEDIA COMMITTEE AND
THEN BACK TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AFTER THE
BILL IS HEARD ON APRIL
NINETEENTH AND FURTHER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING BILLS. AB TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED CARILLO FROM THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE AND AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN QUIRK-SILVA. FROM
THE BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL
BE THE ORDER. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE ITEM
TWENTY TWO AJ ARE TWENTY EIGHT
CRISTINA GARCIA FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CLERK WILL KNOW
THANK YOU. MEMBERS WE HAVE SOME
BIRTHDAY ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY
TOMORROW IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLIES BIRTHDAY. IN SATURDAY
MARCH MARCH NINETEENTH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MISSOURIANS BIRTHDAY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WISHING BOTH
OF THEM ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY
IN THIS AREA HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
MOVING ON TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. ON SECOND READING
FILE ITEMS ONE TO SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
THIRTY SIX OF THE MOMENT SEVENTY
FIFTY WITH THE MINUTES NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO WITH ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN TWELVE THE MEMBERS
NINETEEN SIXTY WITH THEM IT'S AN
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THE MINUTES. ALL BILLS
WHICH WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
ALMOND AMENDMENTS WILL BE DEEMED
ADOPTED. FOR RECONSIDERATION
FILE ITEM SEVEN SHALL BE
CONTINUED. FILE ITEM EIGHT SHALL
BE PASSED AND RETAINS. MEMBERS
WE WILL MOVE ON NOW. TO FILE
ITEM NINE.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIBBY LEVINE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY FORTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE ACKLEY TWO
CORRECTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIVIGNO RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND
HAPPY PURIM EVERYONE I KNOW THAT
WASN'T A HOLIDAY THAT YOU'RE
EXPECTING SOMEONE TO WISH
EVERYONE- I THINK- THE CHAIR OF
THE JEWISH CAUCUS HELP MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE HAMANN TASCHEN
SIGN EVERYONE'S DESK. AND AND
IT'S INTERESTING I'M THE BILL
I'M TALKING ABOUT HAS TO DO WITH
. MIDDLE JUSTICE HEY MAN WHICH
THE HAMANN TASCHEN IS NAMED
AFTER IT WAS A VERY BAD MAN WHO.
YEAH YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BOO HIM
WHEN HIS NAME IS MENTIONED
DURING THE POOR ON THE HOLIDAY.
EVERY SINGLE TIME YOU SEE HIM IN
. ALL RIGHT YEAH YOU GUYS GOT IT
AND- SO THIS BILL IS ABOUT
FLASHING CURSOR ATION WHICH
WOULD NEVER BE APPLIED TO A VERY
BAD PERSON I CAME IN- AB
SEVENTEEN FOR THANK YOU I HEARD
THAT BACK THERE. AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY FOUR WOULD EXTEND THE
SUNSET ON THE AUTHORITY TO USE
FLASH INCARCERATION UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT. SLASH INCARCERATION IS A
TOOL THAT CAN BE USED TO ADDRESS
VIOLATIONS OF AN OFFENDER AS
CONDITIONS OF PROBATION OR
MANDATORY SUPERVISION BY
IMPOSING A SHORT DETENTION. OF
UP TO TEN DAYS BUT NOT
NECESSARILY THAT MANY DAYS AND
CAN BE EFFECTIVE IN THE DITCH IN
DETERRING. FUTURE VIOLATIONS.
INTERMEDIATE SANCTIONS LIKE
FLASHING CAR SERRATION BALANCE
THE NEED TO HOLD OFFENDERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR VIOLATIONS OF
THEIR SUPERVISION WHILE FOCUSING
ON SHORTER DISRUPTIONS FROM WORK
HOME OR PROGRAMMING. SO WITHOUT
FLASHING PERSPIRATION NORMAL
REVOCATION HEARINGS WOULD TAKE
PLACE RESULTING IN LONG COURT
PROCEEDINGS OF UP TO ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS IN CUSTODY FLASHING
CAR STREET AND STOPS THAT FROM
OCCURRING. MAKES IT VERY SHORT
IN DURATION POSSIBLY SAVING
SOMEONE'S JOB OR HOME ACCESS TO
THEIR CHILDREN WHICH IS A VERY
GOOD THING THIS BILL PASSED OUT
OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
WITH STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIVING YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER
THANK YOU HAPPY FOR. I'LL BE
HAVING SEIZE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR- THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE MOVIE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE VOTE TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS FIFTY
FIVE KNOWS TWENTY ONE NO ZERO.
AT TWENTY ONE ABSTENTIONS. THE
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TEN SHALL BE PASSED
ENTERTAINED.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM ELEVEN. H. R. EIGHTY
NINE BY CRISTINA GARCIA- AND WE
RECOGNISE MAJORITY LEADER REYES
TWO PRESENTS THE CLERK WILL READ
ALSO SOLUTION EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
RELATIVE TO WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTY NINE.
PROCLAIMING MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
DURING THIS MONTH WE PAY TRIBUTE
TO THE AMAZING WOMEN THAT HAVE
COME BEFORE US AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE'S STILL MUCH WORK TO
BE DONE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY. AND EVEN
HERE IN OUR STATE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE WE HAVE PARITY IN ALL
LEVELS OF SOCIETY. TODAY WE
CELEBRATE THE FACT THAT TO A
LITTLE OVER ONE HUNDRED YEARS
AGO WOMEN FOUGHT FOR THE RIGHT
TO VOTE AND OUR RIGHT TO SERVE
IN OFFICE BUT TODAY WE MUST ALSO
DOUBLE DOWN ON OUR EFFORTS TO
ENSURE OUR STATE LEGISLATURE
LOOKS MORE LIKE THE GREAT STATE.
WE COLLECTIVELY REPRESENT. A
LITTLE OVER ONE HUNDRED YEARS
AGO THE FIRST FOR WOMEN
ELIZABETH HUGHES. ANNA SAILOR.
ESTO BROTEN AND GRACE STORES
WERE ELECTED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY. SINCE EIGHTEEN FORTY
NINE THERE HAVE BEEN. THREE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN MEMBERS ELECTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY. AND
OF THOSE ONLY ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THREE. ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THREE HAVE BEEN WOMEN. THE
TOTAL NUMBER FOR THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDING THE SENATE
IS FOUR THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN ELECTED SINCE
EIGHTEEN FORTY NINE. ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE HAVE BEEN WOMEN.
ONE HUNDRED YEARS SINCE THE
FIRST WOMEN WERE ELECTED TO THE
STATE LEGISLATURE OUR CURRENT
WOMEN'S CAUCUS MEMBERS CONTINUE
TO MAKE HISTORY AND BREAK GLASS
CEILINGS. HERE IN OUR HOUSE WE
HAVE THE FIRST BLACK LATINO TO
PRESIDE OVER AN ASSEMBLY FLOOR
SESSION. THE FIRST AND ONLY LET
THE END OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY. THE FIRST
REPUBLICAN LATINO IN THE
ASSEMBLY. AND THESE ARE
CHRISTINA'S NOTES IN THE FIRST
LATINO MAJORITY LEADER EVER. OUR
WOMEN'S CAUCUS MEMBERS HAVE NOT
ONLY BEEN BREAKING GLASS
CEILINGS BUT ARE UNITED IN OUR
FIGHT TO ENSURE ALL WOMEN ARE
TREATED RESPECTED AND PAID AS WE
RIGHTFULLY DESERVE. THE PANDEMIC
IS ONLY EXACERBATED AND
HIGHLIGHTED THE WORK WE NEED TO
DO TO LIFT UP ALL WOMEN AND
GIVEN US. AND TO GIVE US A
GREATER SENSE AND THIS IS GIVING
US A GREATER SENSE OF URGENCY.
WE CELEBRATE WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH EVERY YEAR TO RECOGNIZE
THE HISTORICAL ROLES AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THE
TRAILBLAZING WOMEN THAT CAME
BEFORE US. TODAY WE CELEBRATE
AMAZING WOMEN FROM EACH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT WERE WORKING DAY IN AND
DAY OUT TO MAKE THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR GOLDEN STATE
BETTER. IN WAYS BIG AND SMALL
NOTICED AND UNNOTICED LEADERS
LIKE OUR HONOREES HAVE INSPIRED
AND CHANGED OUR COMMUNITIES FOR
THE BETTER. AND KEPT US GOING
DURING AN EXTRAORDINARILY
CHALLENGING TIME. IT IS FOR THIS
REASON THAT WE DECIDED WE MUST
CONTINUE THIS RECOGNITION THIS
YEAR. YOU ALL HAVE RECEIVED A
WOMAN OF THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO BOOK. IT WAS
DELIVERED TO YOUR OFFICES AND
THERE'S ALSO ONE FOR EACH OF
YOUR- HONOREES ALONG WITH A
NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS PROVIDED
BY THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS. THE CERTIFICATE OUR
HONOREES WILL RECEIVE DEPICTS
THE ARTWORK OF A BOOK BY SOLENO
SOLOMON'S CALLED HOW WE WON THE
VOTE IN NINETEEN ELEVEN. THE
IMAGE PORTRAYS A WOMAN PRESENTED
PRESENTING THE SIX STAR TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS
CALIFORNIA WAS A SIX STATE TO
GIVE WOMEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
LET US COME TOGETHER TO
CELEBRATE ALL OF OUR HONOREES
THE TRAILBLAZING WOMEN OF THE
PAST. AND THE HISTORY MAKING
WOMEN OF TODAY AND BEYOND THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO MOVE OUR STATE
FORWARD. THANK YOU REGARDING
LEADER REYES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER CAN YOU RECOGNIZE THAT
YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M HONORED
TO RISE ON BEHALF THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF HR EIGHTY NINE I WANT
TO FIRST THANK THOSE OF YOU THAT
ARE HONORING RUTH BETTER
GINSBURG TODAY SHE AS WE ALL
KNOW IS CREDITED AND WELL
DESERVING OF OUR CREDIT FOR
GIVING US WOMEN MANY. OF THE
RIGHTS WE ENJOY TODAY THAT HAVE
ALLOWED US TO GET TO THIS
ASSEMBLY FLOOR TO REPRESENT OUR
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
SOMEONE THE JEWISH COMMUNITY IS
INCREDIBLY PROUD OF WHO CARRIED
OUR VALUES OF TWO COULD ALLOW
HIM TO THE HIGHEST COURT IN THE
LAND AND DID INCREDIBLE WORK
DURING HER LIFETIME. BUT I WANT
TO TOUCH ON. AT THE HOLIDAY THAT
WE AS JEWS CELEBRATE TODAY.
TODAY IS POOR- THE DOWN WHICH
WE'RE ALSO CELEBRATING THIS
RESOLUTION FOR WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH. JEWS IN HIS LAND WITHOUT
REALIZING THAT HIS OWN WIFE
ESTHER WAS JEWISH. IN HER SAFETY
BEHIND THE CASTLE WALLS. ESTHER
FIRST FALTERED IN SPEAKING OUT.
UNTIL SHE RECEIVED A MESSAGE
FROM HER FAMILY I. DO NOT THINK
THAT YOU WILL ESCAPE THE FATE OF
ALL THE JEWS BY BEING IN THE
KING'S PALACE IT SAID. THIS
MOMENT IS WHY YOU WERE CHOSEN
FOR THE ROLE. IN THE STORY OF
POOR M. ASTER IS. THE HERO. SHE
IS ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO SAVES
THE JEWISH PEOPLE. AND I THINK
IT'S APT TODAY THAT WE REMEMBER
THAT THAT THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY
WHETHER CREDIT OR NOT WOMEN
WHO'VE BEEN. THE HEROES OF MANY
OF OUR STORIES AND IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT ON DAYS LIKE
TODAY BUT ALSO. EVERY DAY WE
GIVE CREDIT TO THE WOMEN WHO
WORK SO HARD TO REPRESENT. THOSE
WHO NEED THEIR VOICES AND FIGHT
FOR RIGHTS FOR EVERYBODY. IT'S
ALSO CRITICAL TO REMEMBER. THAT
IN THIS TIME OF ANY QUALITY OF
ESCALATING GLOBAL GLOBAL CRISIS.
IT'S EASY FOR THOSE WHO ARE NOT
AFFECTED TO SHOT THE CASTLE
DOORS ANDIGNORE THE UFFERING
OF THE WORLD'S. IF YOU ARE A
MAN. WHO ISN'T AFFECTED BY
GENDER INEQUITIES. OR IF YOU
HOLD POWER. IT IS OUR JOB TO USE
THAT PRIVILEGE FOR OTHERS.
BECAUSE AS LONG AS OPPRESSION
STANDS DO NOT THINK HE WILL.
ESCAPE THE FATE OF THE
OPPRESSED. SO FROM THE PANDEMIC
TO THE VIOLENT CONFLICT WE KNOW
WOMEN DISPROPORTIONATELY SUFFER
THE CONSEQUENCES OF MANY OF
THESE DISASTERS. SO AS WE
CELEBRATE WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH
WE WHO STAND IN THIS IMPORTANT
BUILDING. MUST REMEMBER AND
STAND UP FOR THE WOMEN. WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR CAREERS IN THE
PANDEMIC. THE SINGLE MOTHERS WHO
FACE FINANCIAL DEVASTATION. WE
SHOULD STAND FOR THE WOMEN OF
UKRAINE THE WOMEN AROUND THE
WORLD WHO NEED OUR VOICES. THE
HISTORY OF WOMEN. IS A HISTORY
OF STRUGGLE OF SOLIDARITY BUT
ALSO A TRIUMPH AND TODAY IT IS
OUR JOB TO CARRY THAT FORWARD.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AND H. R. EIGHTY
NINE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR EIGHTY
NINE. CELEBRATING WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH I ALSO WANT TO
CONGRATULATE ALL THE WOMEN
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE BEEN
CHOSEN BY YOU HERE IN THESE
CHAMBERS AS YOUR DISTRICT WOMAN
OF THE YEAR WE KNOW THAT THESE
WOMEN COME FROM VASTLY DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES OF PROFESSIONS WE
KNOW MANY OF THEM ARE MOTHERS
LEADERS IN THE COMMUNITY SO
CONGRATULATIONS. SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF OUR LATINO CAUCUS I
WANT TO SAY WHEN PEOPLE THINK OF
LATINOS THE WORD FIERCE
PASSIONATE. AND STRONG OFTEN
COME TO MIND ALL MET SOMETIMES
WE CAN BE EVEN A LITTLE SCARY.
BUT THAT'S BECAUSE WE ARE
WILLING TO STAND UP AND FIGHT.
FROM ASTRONAUTS TO ARTISTS
LATINA TRAILBLAZERS PAST AND
PRESENT HAVE HELPED SHAPE THE
VERY FABRIC OF OUR NATION AND
OUR STATE. SOME OF THESE
EXAMPLES INCLUDE A MARIE
THEODORE AND HER DAUGHTER
VANESSA GILLIAN FROM MY DISTRICT
FULLERTON WHO OPENED UP ZOMBIE
DONUTS WHICH HAS NOW RECEIVED
NOT ONLY MANY AWARDS BUT PEOPLE
LINE UP FOR THOSE INCREDIBLE
DONUTS A MOM AND DAUGHTER
BUSINESS IN FULLERTON. JUSTIN
JUSTICE PARTRIDGE A GUERRERO WHO
MADE HISTORY IN CALIFORNIA BY
BECOMING THE FIRST LATINA TO BE
NOMINATED TO THE STATE SUPREME
COURT. PRISCILLA CORONADO WHO
MADE HISTORY AS THE FIRST LATINO
PRESIDENT OF HARVARD LAW REVIEW
. DIANA THREE PO THE FIRST
IMMIGRANT LATINA TO JOIN THE
NASA ACADEMY AND BECOME FLIGHT
DIRECTOR FOR THE HISTORIC MARS
PERSEVERANCE ROVER. MARIA ELENA
BUT BECAUSE THE A NOBLE PRIZE
NOMINATED MICROBIOLOGISTS WHO CO
INVENTED A CO VIDHAN NINETEEN
VACCINE THAT'S JUST A FEW. BUT
I'D LIKE TO END NOT ONLY
CELEBRATING THE WOMEN'S MENTION
BUT AGAIN ALL OF THE WOMEN THAT
STEP UP IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR LEADERS LIKE TO CLOSE WITH A
QUOTE FROM AS YOU'VE NOTICED
SOME OF US WRE WEARING THESE
COLORS AND THESE COLORS ARE A
TROOPER A TRIBUTE TO RUTH BADER
GINSBURG. OUR SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE WHO WE MISS DEARLY HER
QUOTE IS PEOPLE OFTEN ASK HER
WHEN WILL THERE BE ENOUGH WOMEN
ON THE SUPREME COURT. MY ANSWER
IS WHEN THERE ARE NINE PEOPLE
ARE SHOCKED BUT THERE'D BEEN
NINE MEN AND NOBODY EVER RAISED
A QUESTION ABOUT THAT. ANOTHER
QUOTE IN MY FINAL QUOTE DELORES
HUERTA CO FOUNDER IF THE U. F.
W. AND FEMINIST ICON THE
CAPTURES THE PURPOSE OF TODAY WE
AS WOMEN. SHOULD SHINE LIGHT IN
OUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND NOT FEEL
EGO **** WHEN WE DO THIS. IT'S A
GREAT WAY TO LET THE WORLD KNOW
THAT WE AS WOMEN CAN ACCOMPLISH
GREAT THINGS. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON H. H. R. EIGHTY NINE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID
RUN THIS YEAR RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE LGBT Q. CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF H. R. EIGHTY NINE
THIS IS A NECESSARY OPPORTUNITY
TO HONOR THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
THE VOICES IN THE LIVES OF THE
WOMEN OF OUR NATION'S PAST AND
OUR PRESENT. THE WORK AND MANY
OF THESE WOMEN IS PART OF THE
REASON WHY THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
HAS THE RIGHTS WE ENJOY TODAY
WOMEN HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
MOVEMENTS IT WAS A WOMAN WHO
WHILE HAND CUFFED STOOD UP TO
AUTHORITIES AND URGED THE CROWD
TO FIGHT FOR THE RIGHTS OF THE
STONEWALL RIOTS. IT WAS A WOMAN
WHO PIONEERED GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE IN THE UNITED STATES IT WAS
A WOMAN WHO WERE AMONG THOSE WHO
HELPED CARE FOR ALIEN MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY AT THE HEIGHT OF
THE AIDS CRISIS AND OF COURSE IT
WAS FOR FEARS DETERMINED AND
PASSIONATE ALIGHTED WOMEN JACKIE
GOLDBERG CHRISTINE KEYHOE SHEILA
KEWL AND CAROL MAIDEN WHO CAME
TO THIS BUILDING. AND TOOK THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY'S STRUGGLE TO
SECURE OUR RIGHTS FROM THE
STREETS TO THE HALLS HERE IN OUR
STATE CAPITOL. AS AN ELECTED
MEMBER OF THIS HOUSE I AM PROUD
TO STAND ON THE SHOULDERS OF
THESE TRAILBLAZING WOMAN WHO
CAME BEFORE US WE IN THE LGBTQ
CAUCUS IN THE LARGER LGBTQ
COMMUNITY WILL REMAIN INTERNALLY
GRATEFUL FOR ALL THESE WOMEN WHO
HAVE FOUGHT AND CONTINUE TO
FIGHT FOR EQUAL RIGHTS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE ON
H. R. EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU
MEMBER SAID ABOUT THIS WE WILL
MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
YOUR BIKE FONG YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF
THE ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR EIGHTY
NINE. WHICH RECOGNIZES MARCH AS
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH IT IS AN
HONOR TO HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO CELEBRATE AND RECOGNIZE THE
COURAGEOUS WOMEN WE HAVE SAY
CALIFORNIA INTO WHAT IT IS
TODAY. TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT A HANDFUL THE API
WOMEN HAVE BROKEN THE GLASS
CEILING. AND CONTINUE TO INSPIRE
WOMEN THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
FROM LOCAL TO STATE AND EVEN THE
WHITE HOUSE. AAPI WOMEN SUCH AS
FORMER SUPERVISOR WILMA CHAN.
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE MARCH
FONG EU. TRESOR FEELING A MÀ.
CONTROLLER BETTY YEE. AND VICE
PRESIDENT KHAMA HARRIS HAVE
BROKEN THE GLASS CEILING FOR
GENERATIONS. BEHIND THE SCENES
APA WOMEN SUCH AS THE JOB AMORA.
MAINLY TOM HAVE HELP BRING IN AN
ELEVATOR APA WOMEN IN THIS VERY
BUILDING AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT. THIS IS ONLY A
SLIVER OF THE WOMEN THAT HAVE
MADE A DIFFERENCE AND CONTINUE
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR THIS
GREAT STATE AND NATION. AND
THERE ARE MANY MORE THAT CAN BE
HONORED. AND I URGE EVERYONE TO
JOIN ME IN SUPPORT OF H. R.
EIGHTY NINE. AS WE CELEBRATE ALL
WOMEN. AND THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
EFFORTS HERE IN A COMMUNITY EACH
AND EVERY DAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON HR EIGHTY NINE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES TO
MAKE CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I ALSO REMIND YOU ALL
THAT **** OUR FIRST FEMALE CHIEF
CLERK SUE PARKER IS ALSO SITTING
UP AT THE DICE. AND OUR FIRST.
CHIEF SERGEANT LISA BURKE
BUCKLEY ALSO. ISRAEL FIRST IN
MEMBERS I DO ASK OF THEM SPEAKER
I ALSO THE FIRST ROLE THE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU ALL
THE BEST HAVING SEIZED THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR. ALL
MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE. NUMBERS
THIS IS WITH AUTHORS. THERE ARE. SIX ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO
ROADS THERE ARE SIXTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL NOW TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSED
SAY NO. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEMS TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN THOSE SHALL BE PASSED
AND RETAINED WE'LL MOVE ON NOW
TO SENATE THIRD READING. FILE
ITEMS TO FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN
SHALL BE PASSED AND RETAINS. WE
WILL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN. S. B. TWO FOUR FIVE BYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ A
PRESENTED BY AT DR CULA WEBER.
FOR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY FIVE BY
SOONER GONZALEZ AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE HEALTHCARE COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY FIVE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR LENA GONZALEZ
. THIS MEASURE WILL REQUIRE ALL
STATE LICENSED HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLANS ISSUED AFTER TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO TWENTY TWO TO
COVER ABORTION AND ABORTION
RELATED SERVICES WITHOUT A
COPAYMENT DEDUCTIBLE OR ANY TYPE
OF COST SHARING. CALIFORNIA HAS
LONG BEEN A LEADER IN PROTECTING
AN INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO ACCESS
ABORTION AND WHILE THESE EFFORTS
HAVE HELPED MAINTAIN THIS RIGHT
FOR DECADES THERE ARE STILL
NUMEROUS REMAINING BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING CARE INCLUDING
AFFORDABILITY. HEALTH PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO COVER ABORTION
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA BUT THEY
CAN STILL CHARGE HIGH
DEDUCTIBLES AND CO PAYS THAT CAN
RANGE FROM FORTY DOLLARS TO
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. A RECENT
FIVE YEAR STUDY CONDUCTED BY U.
C. S. F. OF A THOUSAND WOMEN
SEEKING ABORTION CARE AT THIRTY
FACILITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
FOUND THAT OVER HALF OF THE
WOMEN HAD OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES
OF MORE THAN A THIRD OF THEIR
MONTHLY INCOME. THESE HIGH OUT
OF POCKET COSTS ARE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS TO CARE THAT CAN BE
COST PROHIBITIVE TO WORKING
FAMILIES. SB TWO FORTY FIVE WILL
REMOVE THIS BARRIER AND ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS TO ACCESS THEIR
LEGAL RIGHT TO ABORTION. AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS LIVED IN STATES
LIKE LOUISIANA AND PRACTICE AS
AN OBGYN IN TEXAS. I HAVE SEEN
THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF PLACING
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE. AND I
CAN PERSONALLY ATTEST THAT
PROTECTING ACCESS TO ABORTION IS
IMPORTANT NOW MORE THAN EVER. AS
OUR FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
REPRODUCTIVE CARE IS UNDER
ATTACK IN STATE HOUSES ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY AND IN THE CHAMBERS
OF OUR U. S. SUPREME COURT.
CALIFORNIA MUST REMAIN A LEADER
IN THIS FIGHT AND MUST CONTINUE
TO DEFEND AND EXPAND ACCESS TO
ABORTION CARE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB TWO FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OUR CAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND I WANT TO RISE AND
THANK. MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL
AND BEING A CO AUTHOR AND AS
WELL AS SENATOR GONZALEZ FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE WE TALK
A LOT ON THIS FLOOR ABOUT ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE. AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT THEY'RE
NEVER BE BARRIERS TO NEEDED MUCH
NEEDED HEALTH CARE AND I WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR THAT ABORTION CARE
IS HEALTH CARE AND THIS IS
REMOVING A CRITICAL BARRIER WHEN
YOU HEARD OUR COLLEAGUES SAY
THAT A THIRD OF SOMEONE'S
MONTHLY WAGES GO TO GETTING THIS
HEALTHCARE. HERE'S A REAL AND
MEANINGFUL AND THEY'RE STOPPING
PEOPLE FROM GETTING ACCESS TO
THIS HEALTHCARE. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
YOU MAY CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER AYE VOTE ON SB TWO FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. WHERE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THANK. ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO
HIGHS FORTY SIX NO EIGHTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN SHOULD BE
PASSED ENTERTAINS. MOVING TO A
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
FILE ITEMS TWENTY FOUR AND
TWENTY FIVE DOES ANY MEMBER WISH
TO REMOVE ANY ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE THE CLERK WILL READ
THE SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
SYMBOL SIXTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
AND ACTIVATING THE PUBLIC SAFETY
. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE. I SIXTY
FIVE NEWS ZERO THE CONSENT
ALENDAR IS ADOPTED. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SOME OF THE. FIFTEEN NINETY. I SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY THE
QUORUM CALL IS NOT YET LIFTED
MEMBERS MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WHO ARE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. THREE
RESTAURANT. RESERVE.
THIS MCCARTY RECOGNIZING HER
DESK. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
TODAY I ASKED WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF A LONG TIME SACRAMENTO
IN FRANK CAL KANO WHO PASSED
AWAY ON FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY THREE. FRANKAU
KANO OTHERWISE KNOWN AS MR CAL
KANO COACH CAL CONDO OR YELLOW.
BY STUDENTS. BASEBALL PLAYERS
AND FRIENDS THROUGHOUT
SACRAMENTO HE'S FROM THE BAY
AREA MADAM SPEAKER FROM YOUR
DISTRICT GROUP IN OAKLAND WENT
TO FREMONT HIGH SCHOOL WAS A
THREE SPORT STAR ATHLETE LATER
CAME TO SACRAMENTO TO ATTEND
SACRAMENTO STATE COLLEGE. TO
ALSO BECOME A STUDENT ATHLETE.
AFTER HIS. EDUCATION AT SAC
STATE HE WON UP TO OREGON STATE
RECEIVED RECEIVED HIS MASTER'S
IN TEACHER CAN ANSEL REALLY
BRIEFLY CAME BACK HERE TO WORK
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR BUT
REALIZED HIS LOVE AND PASSION
WAS TEACHING AND COACHING.
STARTED HIS COACHING AREER
GRANT HIGH SCHOOL. ABOUT FIVE
MILES NORTH OF HERE. RE COACHED
BASEBALL. HE WAS A- LEGENDARY
COACH UP NORTH THERE I
SACRAMENTO. COACHED THEN STUDENT
ATHLETES WHERE BECAME MAJOR
LEAGUERS LIKE TAYLOR DUNCAN
LERON LEE AND LEON LEE. NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR HE BEGAN HIS CAREER
TEACHING AT EL CAMINO HIGH
SCHOOL MY HIGH SCHOOL HE BEGAN
TEACHING U. S. HISTORY AND
GEOGRAPHY. ANY BECAME A COACH
THERE FOR OVER TWENTY FOUR
YEARS. HE MADE HIS NAME HE MADE
A NAME FOR HIMSELF COACHING
VARSITY BASEBALL. AND JV
FOOTBALL FOR FIVE YEARS HIS MAIN
SPORT WAS BASEBALL HE COACHED
BASEBALL THERE FOR TWENTY FOUR
YEARS. AT OVER FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY WINS. AS A COACH MULTIPLE
LEAGUE TITLES. GROOMING STAR
PLAYERS SUCH AS DIRECTLY FIFTEEN
YEAR MAJOR LEAGUE PLAYER. HE
BECAME THE OPTIMIST COATS FOR
LOCAL SCHOLAR ATHLETES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND WAS INDUCTED INTO
SACRAMENTO'S LA SALLE HALL OF
FAME FOR COACHING IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE. AFTER RETIRING FROM
TEACHING AND COACHING HE DECIDED
HE'D STILL HAVE MORE WORK TO DO
. HE WANTED TO SPEND TIME WITH
HIS FAMILY. HIS WIFE AND HIS
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN GOT A
PART TIME JOB AT THE OLD
BASKETBALL ARENA PEER THAN NOT
KNOWN AS ARCO ARENA REASON I'M
SURE WE COULD TURN AROUND AND
WATCH THE GAME FOR A FEW MINUTES
BUT ALSO I DO ITS JOB. HE SPENT
TIME VISITING MAJOR LEAGUE
BALLPARKS AROUND THE COUNTRY
FOLLOWING BASEBALL HIS PASSION
AND YES MR LACKEY WAS A GIANTS
FAN. HE CHERISHED HIS TIME WITH
HIS FAMILY UP IN THE TAHOE AREA
AT TWIN BRIDGES AT THE CABIN. HE
WAS VERY ACTIVE IN HIS IN HIS
NEIGHBORHOOD UP THERE AT
HERITAGE PARK IN NORTH THE
THOMAS. HE'S MISSED BY HIS
FAMILY WHO WERE WITH US TODAY. I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE HIS WIFE
OVER FIFTY SIX YEARS. IN THE
GALLERY SANDY CAL CONNELL ALSO
HIS SONS KYLE KEVIN AND KEITH.
AND HIS GRANDCHILDREN I BELIEVE
ARE WITH US TODAY. LASTLY AS I
NOTED HE WAS MY COACH AND MY
TEACHER. I KNOW THERE ARE FIVE
OF MY HIGH SCHOOL CLASSMATES WHO
ARE ACTUALLY WORKING IN AND
AROUND TE CAPITAL AND THEY KNOW
ABOUT THIS TODAY THEY'RE
WATCHING THEY REMEMBER COACH CAL
CONNOR THEY TALKED ABOUT HOW
MUCH OF A- HOW MUCH OF A-
PRESENCE HE HAD IN THEIR LIVES.
YOU KNOW THE COACH HUNDREDS OF.
BASEBALL PLAYERS BUT HE COACHED
MORE PEOPLE AND LIFE AS A
TEACHER AS OUR CIVICS TEACHER
AND I THINK IT'S VERY FITTING
TODAY THAT AS A GOVERNMENT
TEACHER HAS A CIVICS TEACHER
HE'S HERE GET BEING RECOGNIZED
IN OUR STATE CAPITOL. I WAS
AGAIN ONE OF HIS STUDENTS AND
ATHLETES I WASN'T A STAR IN THE
CLASSROOM NOR IN THE BASEBALL
FIELD BUT HE WAS ALWAYS VERY.
SUPPORTIVE OF ME AND I KNOW VERY
PROUD THAT I LATER BECAME HIS
REPRESENTATIVE IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. AND I WILL ALWAYS
REMEMBER HIM. AND THE LESSONS
THAT HE TAUGHT ME AND OTHER
STUDENTS AND OTHER PEOPLE AROUND
SACRAMENTO AND SO FOR THAT MADAM
SPEAKER. I ALSO INJURING HIS
MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PARTY WILL MOVE
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. TODAY I RISE AS
HIS BODY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
CALEB CC JACKSON A RESIDENT OF
THE CITY OF CARSON. MISTER
JACKSON DEPARTED PEACEFULLY ON
FEBRUARY SEVENTEENTH. AT THE
YOUNG AGE OF NINETY EIGHT AFTER
LEADING A LONG LIFE OF SERVICE
TO HIS COUNTRY AND COMMUNITY.
MISTER JACKSON AFFECTIONATELY
KNOWN AS CC WAS THE FIRST OF TEN
CHILDREN BY HARRIET AND WILSON
JACKSON. HIS FAMILY WHO WORSHIP
AT PARADISE BAPTIST CHURCH IN
LOS ANGELES WELL THAT WAS THE
FIRST TO TEACH HIM THE VALUES OF
FAITH AND SERVICE AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN YEARS OF AGE CC WAS
DRAFTED TO SERVE IN THE IN WAR
WAR TWO IN THE UNITED STATES.
ARMY LIKE SO MANY. IN OUR GREAT
GENERATION CC SERVED WITH
DISTINCTION. PUTTING AN FACING
IGNORANCE AND RACISM AND BIGOTRY
WHEN HE RETURNED HOME HERE IN
THE TO AMERICA CC WAS A PART OF
THE GENERATION OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN SOLDIERS WHO FOUGHT AND
WON AT DOUBLE VICTORY IN A WAR
WAR TO. HE FOUGHT AGAINST THE
**** ABROAD AND DESEGREGATION
HERE AT HOME. THOUGH THE BATTLE
WAS HARD CC NEVER LOST STRENGTH
OR FAITH. HE'S REMEMBERED. HE'S
HE'S RUDE HE'S REMEMBERED THAT
HIS FAMILY TAUGHT HIM TO EXCEL
IN EVERYTHING THAT HE DID C. C.
EARNED THE RANK OF CORPORAL AND
WAS AWARDED THE VICTORY AND GOOD
CONDUCT MEDAL DURING HIS SERVICE
AFTER RECEIVING AN HONORABLE
DISCHARGE FROM THE ARMY CC
RELOCATED TO LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND EVENTUALLY JOINED
THE CARSON COMMUNITY WITH HIS
FAMILY WHERE HE'S KNOWN TO SERVE
HIS COMMUNITY. HE WAS AN
ENTREPRENEUR. A STRONG ADVOCATE
FOR VETERANS. AND HE HELPED
PREPARE AND DELIVERED FOOD TO
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES IN HIS
SERVICE TO THE HOMELESS HE ALSO
TOOK TIME TO MINISTER TO THEM.
ABOUT GOD THE GOD THEY DESERVE.
C. THREE NEVER MISS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPREAD THE WORD
OF GOD AND THE VALUES OF FAITH
THAT HIS FAMILY TAUGHT HIM SO
LONG AGO. IT IS NOT EASY TO SAY
GOODBYE TO CC BUT I KNOW. HIS
EXAMPLE OF FAITH AND SERVICE
WILL LIVE ON FOR GENERATIONS.
MEMBERS ON OUR TOMBSTONE THERE'S
A DATE THAT WE WERE BORN AND THE
DAY THAT WE DIE BUT IN THE
MIDDLE THIS CALL A DASH LET ME
DECLARE THAT SEES THE LIFT HIS
DASH HELPING OTHERS REST IN
PEACE AND REST IN POWER. THANK
YOU MEMBERS THEIR PERFORMANCE
LIFTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER REQUESTS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. I THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER- AND
IT'S WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I
HAVE TO RISE THIS MORNING. IN
THE MEMORY OF- OF SALINAS POLICE
OFFICER JORGE DAVID ALVARADO.
WHO LOST HIS LIFE IN THE LINE OF
DUTY JUST LAST MONTH. OFFICER
ALVARADO WAS A HERO AND A ROLE
MODEL. ACCORDING TO THOSE WHO
KNEW WHEN HE WAS DRAWN TO PUBLIC
SERVICE HIS COMMITMENT AND
MOTIVATION TO SERVE. WAS LINKED
TO AN AWARENESS. BUT HE COULD
MAKE A POSITIVE DIFFERENCE HAVE
A POSITIVE IMPACT ON OTHERS
THROUGH HIS ACTIONS. OFFICER
EVERADO SERVED OUR NATION IN THE
U. S. ARMY WHERE HE WAS ASSIGNED
TO THE HUNDRED AND FIRST
AIRBORNE. DIVISION AS PART OF
THE SCREAMING EAGLES. IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN HE WAS DEPLOYED
TO AFGHANISTAN WITH THE THIRD
BATTALION HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SEVENTH INFANTRY REGIMENT. AND
EARNED THE PRESTIGIOUS COMBAT
INFANTRY BADGE FOR HIS
GALLANTRY- AMONG US IN COMBAT
OPERATIONS. AND DURING THE
SERVICE THE US ARMY OFFICER
EVERADO WAS PROMOTED TO THE RANK
OF SERGEANT. AND WAS ASSIGNED AS
A TEAM LEADER. UPON HIS
HONORABLE DISCHARGE FROM THE
ARMY. OFFICER ABROAD JOIN THE
COLMA THE POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
SERVE THAT COMMUNITY FOR FOUR
AND A HALF YEARS. HE LEFT THE
COMA- THE POLICE DEPARTMENT OR
HE LATERALED TO PERFORM THE SAME
WORK. FOR THE CITY OF SALINAS
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND HE DID SO
TO WORK ALONGSIDE HIS BROTHER
WHO'S ALSO AN OFFICER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. ALWAYS GIVING 100%
ALWAYS GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND
UNTIL THE VERY END OFFICE
OFFICER OF RADO NEVER NEVER
WAVERED FROM HIS DUTIES
RESPONSIBILITIES. OFFICER
ALTERADO THESE BEHIND A FIANCE.
HIS LOVING PARENTS THREE
BROTHERS NEPHEWS AND NIECES. MAY
WE ALWAYS REMEMBER OFFICER JORGE
DAVID OFFROAD JUNIOR. FOR HIS
COURAGE AND THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE HE MADE IN SERVICE FOR
OTHERS. FOR THE COMMUNITY THAT
HE LOVED AND I ASK THAT WE JOIN
IN HIS MEMORY THIS MORNING THANK
YOU NOW TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
SOMEONE MEMBER US MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DESK TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. WILL NOT WE WILL
NOT RECOGNIZE ANY CHANGE IN
BOATS. IT'S DOING RIGHT NOW.
YEAH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID THE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVIES CHANGES VOTE ON S.
B. TWO FOUR FIVE TWO NOT VOTING
. OKAY SO REGISTERED BURKE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY FIVE NO TO
NOT VOTING. THE SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY MARCH
EIGHTEENTH NO FLOOR SESSION AT
NO CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY MARCH
TWENTY FIRST FLOOR SESSION AT
ONE PM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED AND
RETAINS ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. TO ADJOURN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES- SO MOVES
MR HOLDEN SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY MARCH TWENTY FIRST AT ONE
PM THE QUORUM CALL THIS LIFTED
OR HAS ALREADY BEEN LIFTED. WE
ARE ADJOURNED. IT'S MUCH.